what qualities do you look for in people
when establishing a friendship i mean
friendships you don't want to be too
rational and analytical about them
because
we are talking about friendships but i
think integrity is a really big one
you want to trust someone that you're
investing a lot of your time into
and i think happiness is a big one
you don't want to be around unhappy
people
they'll make you unhappy sooner or later
or you'll have to pull them up
and then for me i like intellectually
curious people because they stay
perpetually interesting
do you have friendships with anybody who
is not very smart
honestly it's rare i i
i do have friends who are not like well
everyone's smart at something so i don't
i don't want to be pejorative and say
that you know they're not smart but it's
just
if they're not intellectually curious
about things that i'm intellectually
curious about and if they're not
constantly learning eventually we'll
just run out of stuff to talk about
and i like to talk which is why i'm on
twitter and periscope
what do you look for when you
when determining your first if a person
is honest or not
well that's a good question kevin the
you
i think i think generally charlie and i
can do
pretty well with the situations we see
but we have to we have to have some
evidence of behavior
in front of us and uh
i would say even there's some
occupations where we're going to expect
to find a higher percentage of people
who behave well than others
but
if we work with someone
over a period of
a few months or more i think we've got
we can come up with a pretty high
batting average
in in terms of how they behave but at
solomon i i think i
i was able to
separate out
the people who i felt very good about
and the people i was a little more
nervous about
uh
fairly quickly among the ones i worked
with actively
but how you spot that precisely
uh you know leave your lunch money on
there
on their desks sometimes yeah maybe
you'll find out in hurry but
we we like people
you know you i mean the the great
example you know is somebody like a tom
murphy where they they're just bending
over backwards all the time to make sure
that
you get the better end of the deal or
that that doesn't mean they're
competitive i mean if you play my golf
game for money or something like that
you know he wants to win the worst way
but everybody
but there are people that just
they don't take credit for things that
they didn't do
in fact they give you credit for some of
the things that maybe they did and
you can you can you can get a feel for
it over time charlie you have any good
guidelines on that
i
i think that people leave track records
in life
and uh so somebody at your age
should figure that by the time he's
22 or 3 well he would have left quite a
track record and the world will be able
to figure you out
so
so i think that
i think track records are
very important and
if you start early
trying to have a perfect record and
in
some simple thing like honesty you're
well on the way to success in this world
[Music]
[Applause]
johnny and yelly one time told me he
said he said when you get older you have
the reputation you deserve you can get
away with that for a while
uh early on buddy by the time anybody
gets to be uh 60 or so they they very
probably have the
reputation you deserve and the truth is
you can have the reputation that you
want
if you
if you list all of the things that you
admire in other people
you'll find out that
almost everything you list you may not
be able to kick a football 60 yards or
something of that sort but every almost
everything you listen the people that
you admire and like
they're qualities that
that you can have if you just set out to
do that and ben franklin do that charlie
oh sure i always say that the
get what you want is to deserve what you
want
i'll have some more of a peanut brittle
[Music]
[Music]
you